of all the scripts you've written which
one has been the one that's the most
close to you most personal story a lot
of them okay I try to write from a place
of you know myself just because I find
it's just the words end up on the page
the most honest that way this is now is
a very personal story if I had known I
was a genius was a very personal story
and this is now sort of a continuation
of that and then there's a piece I have
called unrequited that um is a very
personal story as well it's very much
about finally growing up me finally
growing up not being a douche bag
that's what it is about
is it easier to commit to a project
that's really personal or is it in some
ways almost really uncomfortable and
it's easy to push something into the
back burner because you're like you know
what maybe we shouldn't put that out
there or maybe that's too much
I'm too open in this no I think it's I
think it's easier to go personal for me
the back burner is only reserved for
things that I don't have the money to
make it if I had the funding I'd make
them all I just go right down the line
and just shoot all of them and some
things aren't personal at all some
things are just like stories or like
there's like a topical issue that you
know I find and I want to write toward
that or whatever but no I I would rather
I'd rather put it all out there and be
proud of it
because it's what I wanted to do then
the opposite I'd rather I'd rather be
true to what it is I want to say and the
things I want to say about life and love
and relationships and all of that stuff
so no I don't I don't I don't I don't
try format is it almost like therapy do
you feel like we've been in like a few
years of therapy but yeah the reason I
haven't murdered people was because I
write the scripts it's completely it's
totally it's totally therapy especially
unrequited
I'm unrequited it is it's essentially
the story of how I got past what wasn't
completely unhealthy infatuation to find
and fall for the woman that is now my
wife
and I had to do that in order to do that
I had to grow up because my wife is a
woman a girl she's a great woman and I
needed to I needed to be not just some
dude tooling around in Venice being a
jackass you know I needed to be a guy I
needed to be I need to grow up and
that's that's what that was about
and all of the characters in unrequited
are based on actual people from my life
without exception so that one and this
is now in which all the characters are
really just slices of them myself so
those two are probably the most personal
of the scripts that I've written to date
how is it to see that on screen when
there's like maybe there's a major issue
you're working on you put it in a script
because you believe in being honest with
what you're writing and then you you see
it played out whether it's your
character or it's interesting because I
feel like when I'm writing although that
stuff comes out and I go through the
sort of turmoil I love it as I'm writing
you know once it's in the process of
editing and I'm actually watching it
then it's just okay well this is the
best take and this is the cut and this
is that and you know this is the one
that's got the most vulnerability and
this is the one this shoot
it's got the most emotion let's just go
here let's go there it's very hot I I
guess I tend to compartmentalize pretty
well once I get to that point it's the
writing of it where the work comes out
like you sit there and you're staring at
the page and you read it back like oh I
guess you did just write that
are you gonna do you keep it on page you
hit delete we're gonna do
anxiety's alright so you got a struggle
with that and just keep writing but once
it's written for me for my films once
it's written it it's all right buddy you
know you will say all this time with
writers you know I was like I tell
people all the time I am a thief I steal
from life all the time if you say
something interesting or horrible I will
steal it that will put it in script so
be better around me cuz I will see a
hole I will completely steal it's funny
because like I'd love to take these
characters that are you know broken make
bad decisions because of the conflict
and my wife she's very much like you
know she loves like bad guys versus you
know good guys versus bad guy good guy
overcomes you know so I will tell her
these stories and should just be like
these people of yours
they make horrible decisions and I know
honey this I know let's that's the point
I wonder you know I gotta make bad
decisions to make good decision she's
like I love you I support you no matter
what these characters of yours uh
horrible decisions so that's kind of
money
you